welcome to new gaming Network today I'm
going to show you a method for farming
XP this may not be the fastest method
around but I don't find this quite as
boring as the others I've seen and it
also doubles as bit of sniper training
as well as far as the build is concerned
is pretty simple really you want a
bolt-action sniper with predatory in the
third slot three piece fire crest
accomplished kneepads and the risk
doesn't really matter you want to focus
on electronics as your main but you also
want to make sure you get as much
increased kill XP as you can for
abilities so you want to have fire
turret and seeker mine equips your
talents you want tech support to keep
your fighter turret up for longer
wildfire to have the do more damage
chain reaction to have your secret lines
do more damage and repo Reaper this will
help you have them to stop all the time
run up to find some ammo
right once you've sorted your belt
change to world tier 2 after that fast
travel to the clear sky incursion just
like any of the other XP fast farming
techniques you've probably seen this is
all about the accolade bonuses headshots
using your sniper and multi kills with
your flame targeted secrets
okay start the mission and get running
I'm gonna show you on the map here
basically where you want to run to it
first just ignore all the first enemies
you're gonna be quite squishy because of
your builds that's alright just keep an
eye on it and you should meet this
building quite comfortably once you get
on there jump on top and remove all the
enemies you see notice we reflector on
the flame tone from this angle that does
seem to be the most efficient spot
I'm gonna show you a couple of areas for
when you're running solo this one right
now is probably the easiest one for the
first few times you do it there's
another spot down here that's far more
efficient again because you can get
better angles on your sniping and you
can get your turret into a better
location
[Music]
once the first guys are cleared they'll
start spawning from the lift in the
right to shotgunners from the right and
the rest of them will come from the lift
this is where you want your flame chart
to be from here you just want to focus
on your get shot starting with the
shotgunners first and keep throwing out
those cluster mines
now when you get fast enough you should
get your Acula every few waves but at
first that might seem a little bit
difficult so you may need to run back to
the start every now and then I wouldn't
leave this too long if this is the case
because the numbers start stacked so
high that it eventually glitches out and
can disconnect you Delta you out of the
match the predatory on your bolt action
should stop you having to really worry
about health too much when it comes to
the point where you need more ammo
switch over to your sidearm now you
don't even need to kill anything with
your sidearm as kills from your turret
and in second mines well as you top up
your primary angle as well using this
technique you should get a proficiency
cache every three to four minutes
Alvar for faster caches phone-a-friend
so here I've brought in my buddy ant or
average pants that you've seen online
we're fighting over headshots right now
when were averaging a cache probably
every two to three minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you very much for watching my
first video if you've got any feedback
or comments or questions where I maybe
haven't described things or talked about
things and enough depth to let me know
in the comments below I tried to keep
this nice and brief there's no one like
so those videos are just waffle on and
on anyway Cheers
[Music]
you